so I'm here in Kuala Lumpur Malaysia
there's a prop
okay I'm going on background and I would
like to show you a bit more about the
Superstock is from speakers and their
jupiter ball that is designed to go
inside or maybe the software designed to
go around superval either way
the supertalker i reviewed them before
solid material it's made of this mesh
fabric which reduces the air resistance
seems super durable no stretch which is
good for any kind of tech stuff and he's
now got a few handles I've got the
silicon balls great for throws he's also
got a handle I don't have which is like
clips on for this handle you just make a
knot and wherever you want it to adjust
the length so the jupiter ball I haven't
played with it until very recently
it's basically a juggling ball that's
got two hemispheres you can put a plug
on either side and then it's just a
juggling ball and you can also remove
either side and it's the whole thing's
kind of modular so for instance you can
move it just to let the light shine out
and up the stock boy or you could attach
a lot of things like another ball he's
got the fiber optic that you can cut up
or you could attach if you don't want
sock boy and you'd rather have a like
Colcord tether you could attach that and
then you got your swivel action for
orbitals and whatnot the button on the
bottom holding that lets you make it
brighter the button on the top lets you
make it dimmer each button if you push
it quickly will change to the color or
eventually the mode introducing various
blinking options so what else you need
to know you know they're rechargeable so
just USB port hit
behind the little flap in the side the
only thing I don't like it is definitely
hard plastic and they have pretty decent
weight so if you hit you in the face
full speed that's gonna hurt and at the
juggling Festival I was just that even
dropping it on the floor makes a pretty
loud bang but that's also I think part
of why he managed to keep the price
quite affordable so a set is about sixty
dollars which is pretty good in the
world of rechargeable LED props
another great thing he's Johar has been
releasing some pretty good things lately
that he seems to be listening to the
artists for instance on the website you
can just order individual colors of each
sock so he's made it really easy if you
want one yellow one orange which i think
is a great approach because when you're
trying to figure out air wraps and
orbitals and whatnot it's nice if
there's a different color for each point
so overall I can give it under the
playboy seal of approval so follow the
link go to sweepers he's also got them
selling on Amazon and I will return
making more prop reviews as people send
me more props to review and of course
use my code the code I've got with
Playboy and then you save 5% I make a
commission too and everybody wins
[Music]